before we talk about how to move on the
high fidelity prototypes and bring new
people in on the creation process I want
to step back for a moment and talk about
what you can now do you've learned the
fundamentals of an iterative process
from making a better prototype by
repeating this cycle you will arrive at
a great prototype for a great app and it
will accrue feedback both positive and
negative also remember from the product
design course you may use your design
sprint skills to create new features or
parts of your product we've only gone
along with you for two iterations of
this process and it's important to give
yourself room to iterate learn and grow
many great apps went through 5 10 15
cycles of this process before being
built these cycles of prototyping allow
you to fail quickly and get those bad
designs out of the way remember that
every time you go through a cycle there
are a few steps you need to follow
define what information you're looking
to find modify your current prototype to
match whatever feedback you've already
gotten put your prototype in front of
three to five users collect their
feedback and then analyze the feedback
to see whether you got the right
information as you get better at this
process you'll benefit from learning
more tools in order to build the right
prototype for the right step in the
process will spend the next few videos
talking about those tools